hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round three of
this year's super bit chess classic um
it's richard rapport one of the
candidates of the next candidates
tournament against bogdan daniel dack
we've covered uh some of his games in
the in the past uh you guys probably
know this he is the uh when he became
the international master he became the
youngest ever international master and
also when he became a grandmaster uh he
became the youngest ever grand master
the record has been broken since then
but um uh well that's very very very
impressive uh and also if you remember
he had a brilliant tournament last year
in defeated grand swiss uh he he went
undefeated in nine rounds of brutal
classical chess and now he is battling
it out here on on his home territory
basically as the tournament is being
played in in romania uh against uh uh
well the absolute elite of the elite so
here uh rapper versus doc let's check it
out it's quite a game to enjoy so
rapport with the white piece opens with
d4 and as it is very popular today they
will also play the nimzo indian so c4 we
have e6 knight to c3 and the akka goes
for the names of indian defense bishop
to b4 we have e3 at the normal line we
have castles and now uh knight to e2
bishop to d3 and knight to e2 are the
absolute main lines so this is uh if
it's classical chess most likely this
will be encountered so this is the
bishop attack and this is the arishevsky
variation against the names of indian so
here's c6 preparing to strike with d5 a3
challenging the bishop bishop to a5 and
now usually what uh what you will see
here is b4 bishop moves and then d5 but
here we have c5 and this is very very
much different as you'll see
so here d5 you do not want a backwards
pawn stuck here on d7 so you you have to
advance it right away and c captures on
d6 uh that upper captures this alpha
song uh queen captures and now pawn to
b4 uh we have bishop to b6 bishop to c7
again the usual uh retreating square for
the bishop but uh that prepared very
well uh and bishop to b6 is the move but
rapport also prepared very well as he
knows that dak already played this game
in 2018 uh so uh he is not in unfamiliar
territory as you'll see so bishop to b2
knight beat to d7 and now the game as i
mentioned has been reached in 2018 in
the budapest spring open uh between
abhijit gupta and um
bogdan daniel dakir uh where uh g3 was
played by gupta and uh interestingly g3
is the second uh move recommended by the
engine or maybe even third depending on
what engine you use and the dead game
ended by uh gupta actually winning the
game but here are upward plays knights
the g3 it is the absolute first move
recommended by the engine so rapport
most definitely in familiar territory
here prepared very well and it is now a
completely new game as of move 11. so
let's see how dark uh uh contrast this
we've rooked a d8 uh nicely played as
the d file might open up very soon he
wants to play e5 and it makes sense to
develop the rook to d8 so bishop to c4
you could also consider a more timid uh
developing move like maybe bishop to e2
but uh rapport has a very clear plan he
knows that e5 is the idea and he wants
to go after the f7 pawn so bishop c4 and
queen b3 will do just that but dax is no
not a problem e5 and now the queen to b3
putting pressure on the f7 pawn and here
uh we don't defend the f7 point but
rather e captures on d4 this is what
bogdan plays
and now he says bishop captures and f7
is nothing to worry about so bishop
captures an f7 there is nothing better
for richard uh king to h8 and now e
captures on d4 we have bishop captures
on d4
and rapper castles queen side opening up
a discovery uh well not a discovery
basically the rook is now x-raying the
queen on d6 so you have to be somewhat
careful uh we have knight to e5 now
attacking the bishop on f7 uh and now
what do you play and the problem is if
you play something like bishop back to
c4 although it looks uh very normal it
loses the game on the spot black will
just play knight captures and c for
queen captures queen to e6 attack the
queen and you don't really have a good
retreat square you can go to e2 but now
we play queen f4 check king to b1 bishop
to b3 and this is just i mean
just a disgusting position to play with
white once the rook moves you're going
to play a5 you're going to bust open the
white king's position and um
end the game very very quickly so uh the
castles are on opposite sides of the
board of course um it's the most
important thing to do is to to attack
so here we have knight seat the e4
instead going after the queen here uh
and now the shop captures on b2 with
check queen captures and knight sorry
knights the d3
with check forking the king and the
queen so the knight has to be captured
rook captures on d3 queen captures and
now knight captures on f6 and if you
count the pieces now uh yes dark has two
rooks uh and the bishop of but rapport
has a rook and a bishop and two knights
so
it's uh it's it's a trade-off definitely
and of course the knight cannot be
captured if you capture the knight then
queen captures and f6 is checkmate so
the knight is to remain on f6 for the
moment so queen back to d6 now
threatening to pick up the knight and
knight h to f5 now threatening checkmate
here on g7 uh so queen to h6 would check
queen to f8 uh a bit a bit more solid
but uh you know who who who who amongst
us would not play queen to h6 check so
queen to h6 check uh f for now blocking
check and bishop to g4 very important
attacking the knight but also just
connecting your rooks and gaining uh
more control over the over the back rank
the king is on h8 so the back rank is
very weak queen to e5
uh and now comes a5 like we said we have
to attack the side that's attacking will
win this game and you can see that
rapport has all of his pieces uh in
front of dax king uh so
you have to counter as soon as possible
so b captures on a5 as the queen still
guards the a5 pawn you don't want to
allow a captures on b4 and now rook to
d7 putting pressure on the bishop but
also maybe preparing to double up on the
d file and now comes bishop to e8 now
this is not a bad move but it would be
better to move the bishop to b3 uh
for the simple reason that
next move we can play rook to e1 and
already threaten checkmate so black
would have to react to this and it would
be a valid valuable time taken away from
black uh you know from his own attacking
ideas but here after bishop to e8 now
rook to e1 isn't really all that much
because you have your own bishop here uh
preventing you from
delivering checkmate so okay rook d d8
attacking the bishop and now bishop back
to f7 would be the correct way to go but
here rapper just plays rook to e1 and
now it looks like you might have
something here uh but not not really if
but only if uh
duck finds the only move that doesn't
lose the game for him so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only move or rather resource available
for black to survive this
crushing attack while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
king is in grave danger and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show of
course the movie is king to g8 looks
like a silly move to play you know with
so many pieces in front of your king but
it's actually uh better to have your
king closer to the action than all the
way on h8 where the the back rank
weaknesses are too uh too difficult to
hold so here what do you play okay uh
there are some very nice ideas for
example bishop to f7 check is one of
them uh but knight to f5 is the other
one it's basically the same line only uh
it's a matter of preference do you want
to start with bishop to f7 checker
knight to f5 so rapper starts with
knight to f5 he attacks the queen and
now what do you play the g7 pawn is
attacked three times you have to capture
the knight so bishop captures and then
now bishop to f7 with check and now
rapport's idea is that if the king moves
of course if it goes to f8 then this is
checkmate if it goes to h8 then we're
gonna give up the queen and deliver
checkmate and if king captures an f7
which was played in the game now we play
queen captures on f5 with check king
back to g8 and rook to e7 now going
after the g7 pawn so rook to f8 uh
attacking the white queen if of course
if we capture here with check black can
give up the queen and then black will
also pick up the white queen so queen to
e5 now attacking the g7 pawn three times
and rook f7 defending we have rook to e6
now attacking the queen but now finally
g6 can be played we have knight to f6
with check and now not rook captures on
f6 but rather king the h8 both of these
moves are fine for black but it's
interesting that uh dak chooses this one
because putting your king
on this diagonal looks looks super weird
because uh this is just a force to draw
if rook captures probably why he avoided
it maybe he feels so so confident here
that he just uh knows that he will not
lose this and he wants to push for more
than a draw uh thing is after queen
captures rook to fate and there there's
just no way to
prevent queen captures on f4 we can even
trade queens here and this is now a draw
equal material a rook and game not not
much to look at so here instead king the
h8 and this is now incredibly
interesting there is no good discovery
with the knight if you if you play
knight to the e8 check it it looks scary
but just king j8 there's no continuation
here and if you play something like
knight to g for trying to maybe win the
queen we can just play queen g7 again
not not much for white to look for here
so here rapper plays g4 he wants to
put even more pressure on the on the
black uh black king side uh and then now
uh queen captures an h2 so now with the
h2 upon uh
out of the way and with the black queen
being so active you can see that all
sorts of checks are coming and that it's
very unlikely that you will be able to
get out of them but if you can then you
will still uh probably probably win the
game so rook to d6 we have to be ready
to block check with something like rook
to d1 if if needed queen to h1 check
first king to c2 now queen g2 check and
rook to d2 we block check so here we
have queen to h3 going after the pawn
here now comes king to b2 we defend the
pawn we have queen to f1 uh and now
comes knight captures on h7 this is a
very nice idea the king is in check and
uh if you capture the knight of course
you're getting checkmated rookies do
chucking j8 and rook to h8 will be
checkmate so you cannot touch this
knight but you can play king the g8 and
this is again perfectly fine for dark uh
knight to g5 uh now uh going after the
rook and now just queen captures on f4
now threatening to pick up the queen and
there really isn't uh
anything better here so queen captures
an f4 was played
and uh
okay it's uh it's a very it's a very
tricky idea because the the knight the
g5 actually uh loses the game uh you
have to play knight to f6 check and and
go into this and this is now um well
yeah you're not going to be able to push
with white but with the perfect defense
from black black will be able to defend
and you will not be able to get out of
check this diagonal is uh sufficient to
uh to
uh hold a perpetual uh but instead
knight the g5 was played and now well uh
the end game is completely winning for
doc so queen captures on f4 queen
captures rook captures and now it's two
rooks against a rook and the knight so
this is what uh what rapper missed uh
but it is uh it was a move 40 so uh you
know
you had to make a move to reach time
control and that's probably why why it
happened
rook to d6 now going after the pawn but
it doesn't matter the two rooks are
simply too strong rook captures on a5
rook captures on g6 check king h8 now
knights the e6 attacking the rogue but
just rook f3 and the two rooks will be
able to create uh two too many uh mating
mating uh
uh threats uh for whites to withstand so
g5 uh rapport of course tries pushing
the pass pawn rook captures on a3 have
knight d4 and now rook to h3 rook to d6
now uh we have rook a to g3 and now rook
to d8 to check king h7 rogue d7 check
king to g6 and now rook captures on b7
we have rooked the g to check king to a1
luckily you can meet rook h1 with rook
to b1 uh but there's the simple rook the
a3 with check king to b1 and now rook to
d3 and he was in this position on 52
that rihanna rapper resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you either lose the knight or uh well
you you you you have to lose the knight
and you get checkmated you don't really
get to say in this but if you play
something weird it's checkmate in one
and of course if you try to defend let's
say knight b3 rook to d1 check knight's
the c1 then rogue g1 and that's it we
next we pick up the knight and check
made the white king and of course
there's no this because the pawn is on
c6 blocking the rook from defending
so after look to d3 rapper resigned and
a brilliant brilliant victory for uh
buddha daniel dak who takes his first
win uh in this wonderful wonderful event
uh against none other than rihar
trapport one of the candidates of the
next candidates tournament and i don't
know who he played in the first two
rounds i think he got a okay i'm gonna
check just so i don't strictly i but i
think he he got a draw against nipple uh
yeah he a first round draw against nepal
and second round draw against levon and
now in third round
defeating rapport so uh he's having i
would say a second brilliant brilliant
tournament but it's still three runs
we'll see how it goes for the for the
rest of the tournament for him so big
congratulations on this wonderful
victory for him uh i would like to thank
queen c
bonifate alberto chandrasekhar
venkataramani uh pharmacy and long think
wrong thing uh for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh the the
the cover of this wonderful event and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and also one thing i forgot
to mention is even though it was a
rapport who surprised the ada here
basically with knight the g3 the new
idea uh this is aligned at the dark
place so even though rapper prepared for
it uh a duck is uh you know more well
versed in the intricacies of the of the
positions that can arise and uh
it's not um
it's not at all weird that he he came up
on top here
see you soon